bloomberg news exposes
expos exposes eco hypocrite billionaire
bill gates involvement to save biden's
climate bill
um
gates reportedly didn't just start his
secret efforts to influence manchin and
other u.s legislators to adopt his
radical utopian vision on climate as
gates revealed to bloomberg green
he has quietly lobbied manchin and other
senators starting with biden had won the
white house in anticipation of a rare
moment in which heavy federal spending
might be secured for the clean energy
transition bloomberg said when manchin
expressed hesitancy to supporting new
climate spending gates reportedly saw a
unique opportunity
he taped uh tapped into a relationship
with manchin that he'd cultivated for at
least three years we were able to talk
even at a time when we when he felt
people weren't listening gates
reportedly told bloomberg biden signed
the mammoth climate bill today thanks to
manchin's newfound support during a
ceremony at the white house
how do you i mean there's a lot of
people on the right that actually like
mansion how do you read this article
when you when you hear something like
this i think uh mansion was given a
offer he couldn't refuse wow you're
going godfather's style
got it interesting
interesting and mansion was just
interviewed yesterday by a fox reporter
and said you know you voted for this
uh inflation reduction act
when is it going to reduce inflation and
he said something along the lines of
will it won't it's not like turning on a
switch it's not going to reduce
inflation these people are well aware
that this is a ridiculous title for this
bill i mean you're pumping what 640
billion dollars in the economy it's
ridiculous yeah
well when when somebody does something
they make a 180 degree turnaround you
don't have a good explanation
it's usually because of something that
they don't want you to know and that's
mentioned it's who you're alluding to
yes interesting
but it's not unique to kind of
not put a put a nice little name like
the cares act under trump exactly like
the cares that all right
and even the bill that was the the heels
act the hope act every every
bill that becomes a law is giving a
little marketable name to it though it's
not unique unfortunately you know people
of america
have lost
faith
in our government because of things like
that
because of the way covet was handled
because of what happened in afghanistan
i mean there's just so many
why
why would you have faith in the
government anymore
and it's a severe problem
because if we don't get it back
you know pretty soon
we're doomed
what is dr carson what does this say
about the state of american democracy
that that one senator holds so much
power in his hands
essentially that's what it's come down
to well i guess the question is
how did it get to the point
that we're so
polarized
that one person could have that kind of
power so you don't think this is a
failure in democracy or the way
government functions you think this is a
polarization it's a polarization issue
well i don't think there's any doubt
that america is polarized and if you
want to use the word tribal but let's
give a little respect to joe manchin for
a second because
how many
democrats are getting elected in the
reddest state in the union i mean here's
someone
exactly so
you pride yourself on not making about
yourself working with other people
putting your hand across the aisle
essentially what joe manchin has done
for 40 years
so do you think something actually
changed in the last 30 days yeah or like
you think something happened yeah i
think they made an offer it kind of
refused now what does that what does
that sound like in like behind closed
doors what does that mean i mean is that
death threats is that money
is that uh legacy what is it it could be
any of those things but
he is not a stupid person nope
and you know he weighed
things and says
how do i end up
best off
and he made that decision
so you think he'll just ride off into
the sunset never look for reelection
again you don't think because he helped
pass biden's agenda that the people of
west virginia are going to be done with
you have a hard time with this because
you're a big fan of mansion i do like i
know and by the way most
people do i i i mean you're not in uh
a company where you're the only guy that
likes him the quote what he's saying is
there was an offer made that he can
refuse what that is he doesn't know i
don't think anybody knows but when a guy
named bill
gates gets involved
you're talking about a guy that's got a
lot of ex did you see him when he was
young and he was sitting there going up
against the lawyer have you ever seen
those conversations he had with the
lawyer when he was younger have you ever
seen that video or no yeah of how he
handled the lawyer do you know that
whole scene where mark zuckerberg where
the guy plays him in social networks do
you know that's where the practice came
from watching how gates handled it
you're not talking to a lightweight guy
you're talking about a guy that
he's been he's gotten criticism of
having asperger's which means
emotions low you know this and obviously
he's known for having a temper but you
know at the same time when a guy like
gates gets involved he's got many
creative ways of pushing things through
right he's not a lightweight this is a
very heavyweight guy that got involved
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]